als während die tänzer von unsichtbaren
bändern gezogen bewegen sie sich durch
den raum
eine fließende körper welle
tanzen ist eine mystische sache
tanzen ist mein leben
die musik minimalistisch jede bewegung
tausendmal gehört sechs stunden jeden
tag
[Musik]
ich reduziere ganz bewusst die musik und
die beleuchtung der bühne
meine kunst besteht im fokussieren auf
das wesentliche so kann ich die kraft
des körpers besonders zum ausdruck
bringen
pauli ist der gründer einer der
berühmtesten tanzgruppen in china heute
übt er zwei choreografie seine mission
modernen tanz populär zu machen
er hat die kreisförmigen bewegungen als
seinen stil erfunden
es geht wie so oft in china um die
harmonie
ich will dass die körper sich in der
gleichen geschwindigkeit bewege was gar
nicht so einfach ist denn jeder macht
fehler auf der bühne
das können doch zuschauer sofort sehen
deshalb müssen sich alle tänzer ständig
verändern und anpassen
es ist wie im richtigen leben hinter der
leichtigkeit steckt hartes training
rund ein halbes jahr arbeiten sie an
einer darbietung war selbst tänzer er
hat die schritte und bewegungen erdacht
ihr müsst die ganze bühne im auge haben
damit ihr seht wie der andere sich
bewegt
das trauma der pandemie hat diesen tanz
inspiriert die hoffnung eine mögliche
interpretation tagesperformance ist
immer nur eine andeutung nur sie hat
einen soloauftritt huang lee tanz seit
zehn jahren die philosophie dieser tanz
ist von dem ausbruch der pandemie
beeinflusst die bewegung sind wie eine
zeremonie wie ein kraftvolles gebet vor
dem heutigen auftritt sind alle ein
wenig nervös denn die truppe hat sechs
neue tänzer zu integrieren für ihn geht
ein traum in erfüllung
ich heiße bocelli ich will mit meiner
körpersprache überzeugung
sie sind wie eine familie
wer sich gut verstehe tanze auch gut
miteinander
sagen sie uns graut theorie kommt aus
armen verhältnissen
er träumt es seit seinem zwölften
lebensjahr tänzer zu werden er ist der
erste künstler in seiner familie meine
familie verstehen nicht was ich mache
keiner von ihnen hat sich mit kunst
beschäftigt sie sind gewöhnliche
großartige war
[Musik]
die pandemie hat die pläne von tau
durcheinandergewirbelt an eine
welttournee ist moment nicht zu denken
deshalb reisen sie durch ganz china in
die großen städte wie shanghai und
peking
aber auch in die exklusiven ferienorte
wie hier nach anaya dort macht chinas
reich gewordene mittelschicht urlaub
kunst gehört zum vornehmen
freizeitangebot
und tanzkurse will seine philosophie der
harmonie der beweglichen körper weitere
du musst dein gewicht auf seine knie
verlagern
das ist doch gar nicht so schwer jeder
könne lernen mit seinem körper zu
sprechen die neu zu erfahren
ich bin ein wenig dick mein körper
braucht training so lerne ich ihn besser
zu verstehen
der kurs hilft mir den code meines
körpers zu entschlüsseln
kurz vor dem auftritt am abend im kopf
die bewegungen noch einmal durchgehen
sich auf den anderen einstellen eins
werden
die tanzgruppe wirkt sehr chinesisch
heute treten einige von euch zum ersten
mal auf aber für jeden tänzer gibt es
das erste mal der erste auftritt ist
etwas besonderes aber in meiner welt
sollte jede performance wie beim ersten
mal seien einzigartig
[Musik]
juni ist mitte vierzig und von anfang an
dabei eine tanz legende in china seit
mehr als 30 jahren strebt sie nach
perfektion ihre besprechung nach der
aufführung ist wichtig für die jungen
sie müssen verstehen dass tänzer nie
aufhören zu lernen
ich vergleiche die tänzer oft mit
kriegern denn unsere arbeit ist
schwierig wir müssen die
körperbewegungen mit dem bewusstsein
synchronisieren es geht dabei um mehr
als nur um tanzschritte es geht darum
den körper mit der seele im einklang zu
bringen
dies ist nicht einfach irgendwann wird
auch wieder auf der ganzen welt
auftreten denn irgendwann ist die
pandemie vorbei dann bräuchten die
menschen kultur um ihre geschundenen
seele zu heilen
daran glaubt sie
[Musik]
tanzen ist heilig wenn du dich auf die
bewegung konzentrierst dann kannst du
diese heiligkeit übertragen ich will
dass wir das heilige gefühl beim tanzen
stuhl
[Applaus]